ghostbusters Chris Tucker hello guys I'm
Greg Alba and I'm John John and I today
are gonna watch the second trailer for
the highly anticipated love fest that is
going on right now for it goes yes I've
never seen an audience so enthused about
a reboot before people are loving this
trailer I'm excited for it
I already saw here that it has like a
significant amount more likes than
dislikes yeah okay let's do this I'm
enthused Kristen Wiig Melissa McCarthy
oh my god I'm such a horrible person I
don't remember the other two names Oh
Leslie Jones yeah and Kate McKinnon
Leslie Jones is the one replacing Ernie
Hudson yes cool let's hit play it will
give every nice whatever it is no one
should have to encounter that kind of
evil oh except you girls I think you can
handle it okay thanks
we have a gift we see what no one else
is willing to see we do things others
can't do if there's a paranormal problem
we are the ones to answer the call what
do we think of these ghostbusters are
they maybe take it a serious okay so I
don't know if it was a race thing or a
lady thing but I'm mad as hell there's a
bigger picture at hand here someone is
creating a device that amplifies
paranormal activity we're gonna need a
bigger boat hey guys check it out
I was born to be the gunfire all right
oh man that's so not good
something big is gonna happen the
government's trying to claim the event
isn't supernatural I don't want a panic
you don't want miss area no I'm tired no
no I'm just gonna go ahead and take off
how about that I going to take off don't
piss off the ghost
I want to be honest yeah because I feel
I feel like I do have like an initial I
don't want this to happen kind of thing
no way mmm I told him that when he takes
care of those bodies he does it after 6
p.m. yeah I mean that's when all cops go
to sleep for the cartel know so they
they he doesn't have to worry about them
bothering him Robbie Jones is it works
for the cartel I was like alright you
know what man I'm gonna keep my guard a
because I'm like this is the second
trailer yeah I'm gonna watch this and I
mean I'm like hey it's fine hey it's
hard to not have at least some kind of
weirdness going into this trailer it's
everywhere that this is a controversial
movie you know a lot of people really
don't like that this is happening and a
lot of people are like yeah shut up man
it's cool I don't think it's possible to
not think a little too hard about the
Ghostbusters trailer it's like okay was
this trailer better than the first one I
will say yes for sure it's shown me more
exciting things more thing ever it
leagues that also threw me off though a
lot more it showed me some things that I
like to see like they seem like they're
going for it and they're bringing some
of the crazier more fantastical spirit
that those older spooky comedies had and
it seems like it's a lodging it's
clearly showing its love for a lot of
horror movies but here's the main
problem with this trailer still yeah and
the main problem with the movie overall
yeah the characters don't look appealing
they don't I'm not appeal to them like
what whatsoever I like I'd rather go to
watch like all the cool visual effects
and [ __ ] well like the spooky ghosts and
everything isn't like those ghosts look
spooky and creeping there's like
throwback vibes to them I actually get
you there and I feel like the first
trailer almost had a little bit better a
handle on that because cuz in this trick
like what I would do if I was
advertising this movie is I would take
one long scene of the four of them and
put that out I only get a vague sense
for who each of these characters are in
like high-stress situations but like
when they're really just gonna be
together in the office or in the lab
bantering I want to get a sense for
what that is that I don't have yeah yeah
that's my point
I know these actresses are capable of
reading like great performances and
maybe they have like great chemistry in
the film I don't know but that's where
this film really is essential to making
it work and to be accepted is we need to
know this cast is gonna at least deliver
and I get why they might have steered
away from that because it seems like no
one's gonna be accepting of it until at
least they see the final piece and maybe
they'll change your mind I feel like
what this trailer gives us and and what
it what the stuff about it that I like
is this trailer definitely shows us that
like they are honoring the spirit I feel
like I feel like they're going for and
especially with the stuff they added
into this one with more ghosts and a
little better of a sense for what's you
know happy with one of the ghosts to
come out and stuff it feels like kind of
a creepy kooky you know comedy that way
it seems like it's allowed to get more
broad the way you know comedies don't as
much now the only thing that worries me
is just when it gets to be like a
[ __ ] Marvel movie and like the skies
open I wasn't enjoying it's like okay I
know and Ghostbusters 1 it does get like
[ __ ] crazy by the FIH alley but the
most of the adventure though is you know
it's like it's big of course what's kind
of not subtle yeah but it's not [ __ ]
you know what Hollywood does today it's
not overblown all the time well it's
also not that CG is bad but it's also
not all CG so like certain things you
know are kind of there or at least
processed in and they're shot as real
subjects whenever they add a ton of CG
to something that they're updating I'm
always kind of cautious about that it
could tip the movie over or it could
work it just I don't get a good sense
for if it will even when it tips the
movie over is when it gets carried away
with that stuff work they care more
about that than they do the actual
character yeah
or storytelling you know well yeah I
mean I'm gonna watch this when it comes
I got I want these I have to see this
see this and I want this to be good
I'm really hoping they made a good movie
with all the cool stuff they have like
this is one of those trailers where
people are clearly clicking on the
trailer hating the dislike button before
they even while the trailer want to you
gotta see this movie see how it feel
like
turns and if I like it I'm gonna totally
stand by my opinion and I will share
that gladly even if the movies getting a
lot of hate and I happen to like it I'm
probably good I like I'm still gonna
stay true to my opinion I really want to
have fun with this like and I feel like
there is potential that they could
capture that Ghostbusters spirit you
know I'm just you know I hope they do
because it'd be fun to go see
Ghostbusters again what did you not it
would be fun yeah so I don't know I mean
if you know the cast was returning like
well aren't they all coming back in
cameos whether or not is they're not
playing the characters they're playing
new people know interesting uh I guess
it's kind of like a half blessing then
it's like oh cool they're all back so so
it's cool I just have to see if whatever
new characters they become are special
you know how awkward would it be if they
brought Harold rain eases corpse if he
was cool with that if you like requested
that that might actually be kind of
Awesome you can't do anything with my
body unless they make another ghost
ghost but I'll let there be another
Ghostbusters movie without me well guys
yeah thanks for tuning in if you're new
to the channel subscribe today become a
reject worth your time my time whatever
others should I say John reasons to
Jerry is his dick on here and blue Mouse
calm yes mmm is what he does there hi
Anne thank you I know what you're
getting now he's not no no si mmmm fm
my wife what's that movie from mr. boss
was three no man what born on the 4th of
July a long queue